هل سألت المفوض بول رول من
شرطة جزر الباهاما الملكية إذا كان لديهم أي
مؤشر
حول أسباب الوفاة في هذه الحالة ،
قال في هذه المرحلة أنه لا يزال من المبكر جدًا إجراء
عمليات تشريح الجثة
لمحاولة الإجابة على هذا السؤال ولكن
هناك بعضًا مبكرًا  النتائج التي تعتبر
أساسية هنا حتى الآن لم يعثر محققوه حتى الآن على
أي علامات على وجود تلاعب قائل بأنه
لم يكن هناك أي صدمة تم العثور عليها على
تلك الجثث ، تم
استدعاء محققيه إلى الصنادل في منتجع خليج الزمرد في
الزوما صباح يوم الجمعة بعد أن
اكتشف الموظفون الجثة.  لرجل في إحدى
الفيلات الخاصة بهم ، ثم اكتشفوا
جثتي شخصين آخرين ، رجل
وامرأة في فيلا ثانية على أرض الواقع ،
يقول المحققون إنهم أظهروا
علامات تشنج في الوقت
الذي تم العثور عليهم فيه ، أخبرني المفوض
أن  كان ذلك الزوجان اللذان تم العثور عليهما في
تلك الفيلا الثانية قد لجأوا بالفعل إلى
منشأة طبية محلية في الليلة التي
سبقت وفاتهم كانوا
يشكون من الغثيان
والقيء  إن هذا دليل على أنهم
عولجوا ، ثم
أُعيدوا في النهاية إلى المنتجع ليلتهم ،
كان هناك شخص رابع تم العثور عليه في
تلك الفيلا ، وهي امرأة كان يجب
نقلها جواً ، وأخبرني
المحققون أنها لا تزال تُعالج وتُمرض
في  في المستشفى الآن
، أصدروا بيانًا في
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
كتبوا فيه حالة طوارئ صحية تم
الإبلاغ عنها في البداية واتباع
بروتوكولاتنا ، قمنا على الفور بتنبيه
المتخصصين في الطوارئ الطبية
والسلطات المحلية ذات الصلة ،
وتواصل الشركة الكتابة بأنها
تدعم حاليًا كلا من التحقيق
وأيضًا أسر المتضررين
وبسبب الخصوصية لا يمكنهم الإفراج
عن الكثير كثيرًا الآن عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالجهود التي تحدث
هذا الصباح أخبرني
المحققون أن سفارة الولايات المتحدة هناك في جزر الباهاما على
طول  مع وزارة
السياحة التي تعمل حاليًا مع
السلطات لتحديد هؤلاء
الأفراد الثلاثة بشكل إيجابي  أنه
يمكنهم المضي قدمًا في إجراء
عمليات التشريح التي نأمل أن
تخبرهم كثيرًا عما حدث
يوم الجمعة. كريستي أليكس